hey this is presh talwalkar
i came across a fascinating story in
physics today titled albert einstein and
the high school geometry problem
the article is worth reading in its
entirety and i've provided a link in the
video description
in the rest of the video i'm going to
summarize some of the main points of the
story and focus on the geometry problem
itself
the year was 1952.
and a 14 year old student johanna
mankowitz was struggling with a geometry
problem
this is a bit of a hollywood story
because johanna's father was hermann
menkowitz who co-wrote the screenplay
for citizen kane and her uncle was
joseph mankowitz the famous producer and
hollywood director
johanna decided she didn't know the
answer
so who could she write to for help
she thought about a 73 year old albert
einstein
she wrote a letter with the problem and
she asked
i realize that you're a very busy man
but you are the only person we know of
who could supply us with the answer
unknown to johanna is that albert
einstein would occasionally write back
to students who he felt were sincere so
he wrote back to johanna
he didn't solve the problem exactly but
he did provide some hints and a general
method for solving these kinds of
problems
so what was the problem
it actually was something of a standard
textbook question
what is the length of the common
external tangent to two tangent circles
of radii eight inches and two inches
interestingly
the story got into the media and at
least 82 newspapers covered this story
one might say that this math problem
went viral
so what is the answer to this question
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before i solve the problem i want to
review a famous principle
if two circles a and b are tangent at a
tangent point t
their centers and the tangent point are
collinear
the reason is that a t will be
perpendicular to the tangent line and b
t will also be perpendicular to the
tangent line through t
therefore atb will be a straight line
segment
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
so now let's solve the problem
first we'll construct a line
then we'll take a circle and make it
just tangent to this line
suppose this circle has a radius that
has a length equal to a and we'll
construct a radius that's exactly
perpendicular to this tangent line
now let's construct another circle along
this line that's tangent to it and make
it just tangent to this larger circle
again we'll construct this radius and
suppose that this radius has a length
equal to b
we want to solve for the length of the
common external tangent that's the line
segment that's highlighted
so how do we do that
first we will construct a line segment
between the two centers of the circles
this will go through the tangent point
so these lengths will be equal to a and
b
and together they will be equal to a
plus b
now let's construct the following
horizontal line
then this segment will also have a
length that's equal to b
and the remaining length will be equal
to a minus b because the entire radius
is equal to a
from here we can focus on this right
triangle and this horizontal leg is
exactly the length of the common
external tangent
so we just need to solve for the length
of this leg
because we have a right triangle we have
x squared plus the quantity a minus b
squared is equal to the quantity a plus
b squared
from here we just solve for x
we'll subtract the quantity a minus b
squared from both sides
then we'll expand each binomial the a
squared terms will cancel
and the b squared terms will cancel
then we have 2a b plus 2ab so that'll be
equal to 4ab
we take the square root of both sides
now we want x to be a non-negative value
because it's a length so we just take
the non-negative square root
then the square root of 4 a b is equal
to 2 times the square root of a b
so that is the length of this leg
we go back to our original diagram and
that's exactly the length of the common
external tangent
to solve the problem
we just recall that one circle had a
radius that was equal to eight inches
and the other circle had a radius that
was equal to two inches
so we just need to calculate two times
the square root of eight times two
eight times two is equal to sixteen
then the square root of sixteen is equal
to four
two times four is equal to eight and
thus the length of the common external
tangent is equal to eight inches and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you